this morning our series the dish visits
a new mexico bakery that started as a
passion project and is now getting
national recognition like a lot of
americans many of us here at cbs
mornings turned to baking while we were
stuck inside during the pandemic but few
took it as far as the couple behind
albuquerque's ihatov nominated for one
of the food industry's highest honors
janet chamleon shows us how they created
a neighborhood hub when their community
helped get the project off the ground
[Music]
when baking bread became a pandemic
passion
nobu mizushima was there for it
but it wasn't just a flash in the pan
for the albuquerque man and his wife
yuko as lockdown closed businesses
everywhere the couple decided to open
one and go pro we are doing the farmers
market on weekend
so people customers asking us where can
we buy the bread weekday so
we are thinking like oh my god we should
open the business
in albuquerque's trendy nob hill
neighborhood filled with late night
clubs and restaurants
the couple bet on early mornings opening
an artisan bakery iha tov bread and
coffee in an old arby's fast food joint
the lines on saturday were out the door
you know because there was nothing like
this and it made for community
neighbors were on board from the start
coffee and a poor haircut supporting a
kickstarter campaign to the tune of 16
thousand dollars a lot of dough for the
couple's dream come true how important
was the kickstarter to getting used
launched here it was so important i
think without kickstarter we couldn't
make it we couldn't open the business
now the store regularly sells out of its
sourdough buttermilk biscuits croissants
and some really nice buns
nobu who learned his craft at another
bakery is the creative using japanese
and european techniques like a package
yes
yes but insist he doesn't run the show
oh you're good what is it like working
with your wife
as a co-worker
[Laughter]
yeah actually i enjoy that who's the
boss
she's born
your husband says you're the boss is
that true
i don't i don't know i wanna
[Laughter]
teamwork the ingredient that's made this
little bakery a story of pandemic
prosperity i know they opened right when
everything shut down and yet they've
been hugely successful that shows just
how good
they are
how about great earth bakery and coffee
this year was named a james beard
semi-finalist one of the highest honors
in the food world we were shocked i
think at first nobu wasn't even
necessarily aware of what the james
beard award was and when we
talked about what that meant he was like
oh really wow
rising to the occasion a legend in the
baking
for cbs mornings janet chamlion
albuquerque
now speaking of james beard award
winning you had some trench in food
analysis there during the piece what did
you say about that bread bread is so
delicious that is right on yeah here's
why don't we have any here that's a
great question
you know we always gonna get that is to
fall asleep right at the table that's
true the post-eating bread is my bread
and butter there you go